le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
les fêtes de fin d'année sont pour les
enfants un moment attendu avec
impatience le sapin de noël les
flamboyants en fleurs la douceur du
climat
tous ces indices rappelle à nos
marmailles qu'ils vont passer un beau et
grand moment de joie et de bonheur
c'est généralement en famille que les
fêtes se prépare mais le conseil général
tient aussi à participer au bonheur de
la jeunesse réunionnaise l'aménagement
de lieux et la création d'activités leur
sont proposées pour qu'ils puissent
s'amuser à prendre et profiter de cette
belle période
c'est à la bibliothèque départementale
de la réunion qu'un grand nombre
d'enfants profitent des activités qui
leur sont proposées tout au long de
l'année
ce bâtiment moderne lumineux et
accueillant a été entièrement refaits
pour que nos marmailles puisse y venir
avec envie divers ateliers ils sont
proposés écriture peinture collage
lecture et bien d'autres participent à
l'épanouissement de nos marmailles des
artistes viennent aussi faire partager
et découvrir leur art et leur passion
aux enfants pour leur ouvrir les yeux
sur d'autres découvertes et leur
permettre d'avoir une nouvelle approche
des livres et de la lecture
c'est le cas de ingrid varon qui partage
son art tout au long de l'année avec des
jeunes enfants
plus qu'une passion ingrid partage sa
philosophie de vie avec les plus jeunes
un fonds de keyser ou une faune casey's
c'est une personne qui dit son fond de
guerre à la réunion le fonds de caisse
une forme poétique dans la langue
maternelle
donc comme je suis réunionnaise en
créole réunionnais et de manière
beaucoup plus universel le fond de
caisse est ce qu'il ya au fond du coeur
c'est ce qui vient du moins du fin fond
du coeur donc c'est le point de
rencontre on va dire entre la poésie une
expression de soi
moi je propose des ateliers d'écriture
des ateliers fonnkèr ou
j'accompagne un peu l'enfant dans
l'expression de ses sentiments de ses
émotions ou tout simplement de ce qu'ils
voient de ce qui l'entourent ce qu'ils
constatent des questions qui peut avoir
à se poser en créole ou en français
enfin dans la langue
que le marmaille la envie de causer quoi
ce qu'il faut c'est que ça vient du fond
du coeur et que ce soit le plus naturel
possible en fait pour pouvoir
communiquer au plus juste sans
frontières font de khazri en fait c'est
tout l'art de communiquer son folk et a
donc l'idée c'est que ça vient des mots
ça vient aussi de ce qu'on voit et
et des émotions qu'on peut ressentir
donc le fonds qui a ses atouts c'est le
corps le mental et puis les émotions
donc forcément il se passe quelque chose
le marmaille ce sens a été appelé et il
vit ville émotions de l'artiste aussi en
fait bien plus qu'une passion c'est une
philosophie de vie en fait le fond de
guerre c'est d'apporter un regard sur
moi même et sur ce qui m'entoure et puis
me donner des règles de vie pour avancer
le mieux possible dans l'avenir grâce à
l'intervention d'artistes et au
personnel de la bibliothèque
départementale
c'est toute l'année que les enfants
profitent dans la joie de ces moments
associant culture connaissances et
savoir vivre ensemble des ateliers sous
des formes diverses sont aussi proposés
dans les autres établissements culturels
du conseil général ainsi que dans son
atelier bois de goyavier c'est pour
faire rêver les enfants mais aussi pour
montrer tout le savoir-faire des
services du conseil général depuis
l'animation culturelle jusqu'au bois de
goyavier en passant par les murs
végétaux pour le soutien au monde
agricole que le jardin de l'état se
transforme en bonheur des enfants
du 14 au 22 décembre
le jardin de l'état devient le château
enchanté du conseil général pour
émerveiller bien évidemment les enfants
à la veille de noël et pour les fêtes de
fin d'année mais c'est l'occasion
surtout de montrer que le conseil
général possède des savoir faire que nos
agents peuvent créer des choses
extraordinaires avec le bois de goyavier
mais aussi avec tout ce qu'on fait à la
bibliothèque départementale des jeux à
l'icône hotech donc au fond nous nous
occupons pas seulement du social
nous faisons aussi rêver parce que nous
apportons de l'unige et néry humaine
tout au long de l'année
alors venez tous découvrir le monde
enchanté du travail des agents du
conseil général au bonheur des enfants
donner de la joie aux plus petits
montres et les savoir-faire du conseil
général le faire rêver petits et grands
l'occasion de finir l'année en beauté
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais